[Musique]
une commission séculaire qui veut que la
cour de la sorbonne soit considérée
comme inviolable
pourquoi alors y avoir fait rentrer les
forces de vente
les forces de l'ordre comme vous dites
ne s'entend très que parce que les
forces du désordre était entré vendredi
après-midi à partir de 3h avant trois
centaines d'étudiants se sont installés
dans la cour de la sorbonne une bonne
centaine étaient armés de gourdins de
manches de pioches et même de pioche et
ceux d'entre eux qui n'étaient pas armés
se sont armés de même en cassant des
chaises et les tables de manière à se
servir des pieds de ses chaises et des
pieds de ses tables comme de gourdins à
ce moment là un autre groupe n'ont pas
d'extrême gauche celui-là mais d'extrême
droite a essayé d'entrer dans la cour de
la sorbonne c'est à ce moment là que le
recteur de l'université de paris a fait
appel au gardien de la paix municipaux
comme il en a parfaitement le droit
simplement parce qu'ils étaient sur
place juste de la situation je me couvre
entièrement il était juste de la
situation
il estimait que les choses empiraient et
que s'il y avait violent comme vous
dites de la cour et à sang ban par les
gardiens de la paix municipaux c'est
qu'il y avait eu viols auparavant par
des étudiants armés parmi lesquels
d'ailleurs il y avait des gens qui
n'étaient pas des étudiants qui
n'avaient rien à faire là il ya quelques
jours monsieur le ministre a déclaré
qu'il s'agissait d'une poignée
d'agitateurs et des responsables du
désordre actuel
si vraiment il n'y avait qu'une poignée
de trublion c'est votre terme vous aviez
employés croyez vous vraiment que les
manifestations aurait revêtu l'ampleur
qu'on a connu vendredi et aujourd'hui
vous et je crois que il ne faut rien
exagérer les manifestations de vendredi
et d'aujourd'hui sont profondément
déplorable profondément regrettable mais
elles sont loin jusqu'à maintenant
d'avoir connu en ampleur et en violence
les manifestations qui sont déroulés à
berlin
à varsovie à bonn à rome à alger à
louvain et même à columbia pas plus tard
que la semaine dernière aux états unis
oui mais en france on a tendance à
minimiser nos manifestations
en les comparant à celle de l'étrange
mais cela a quand même été très sérieux
puisqu'il ya eu des blessés et même un
gardien de la paix à et reçu une pierre
sur le crâne il a failli mourir il a été
dans le coma pendant plusieurs jours
c'est quand même très sérieux bien sûr
que c'est sérieux c'est même grave et je
suis le dernier a minimisé ces
manifestations et il faut se rendre
compte quand même que en france
nous avons six ans 5000 étudiants 514000
en faculté 91000 en institut
universitaire de technologie en grandes
écoles et en classes préparatoires aux
grandes écoles
sur ses six ans 5000 étudiants il y en a
600 milles qui travaillent
d'arrache-pied à la préparation de leurs
examens
alors il ne faut pas exagérer la
proportions que tout cela prend même
dans l'université de paris il ya 160
mille étudiants l'immense majorité de
ces étudiants veut travailler en paix et
les forces de l'ordre n'interviennent
que pour protéger ceux qui veulent
travailler en paix
que comptez-vous faire ce que je compte
faire c'est dire oui au dialogue
constructif et non à la violence il faut
mettre fin à l escalade de la violence
il faut avant tout des passionnés il
faut ramener le sang froid faut ramener
le calme
il faut permettre à chacun de réfléchir
ce n'est pas parce que les enragés de
nanterre font des manifestations
violentes pour la paix au vietnam que
paris a été choisi par les deux
belligérants pour les négociations n'a
pas fait ce serait plutôt le contraire
c'est au contraire parce que paris est
la capitale pacifique d'un pays
pacifique
il est donc nécessaire de ramener le
calme
il est nécessaire que la paix se fasse
fait nous et les motifs de violence se
retourne contre ceux qui les agitent ce
qui est souhaitable c'est que le
dialogue se développe que le calme
s'instaure que les examens se passe
temps paix et que les cours reprennent
ces prochains jours
à nantes est né à la samba c'est ce que
nous souhaitons monsieur le ministre
vous avez 42 ans
vous êtes entré au gouvernement à 36 ans
il n'y a pas si longtemps donc vous
étiez encore étudiant vous mais vous
sentez vous du côté des jeunes ou du
côté des anciens écoutez le gouvernement
n'est pas l'instrument des jeunes contre
les vieux ou des vieux contre les jeunes
il n'est pas un instrument des étudiants
contre les professeurs ou des
professeurs contre les étudiants
il est l'instrument il est l'interprète
de l'intérêt national par conséquent ce
que souhaite le gouvernement sait que
l'international soit respecté dans cette
affaire l'intérêt national c'est que
l'université travail en paix
l'international c'est que l'université
se modernise mais ne peut le faire que
progressivement
l'intérêt national c'est que
l'université s'ouvre à la société et la
société à l'université
c'est une tâche magnifique à laquelle
tous professeurs étudiants doivent
collaborer et c'est ce à quoi je les ai
[Musique]